POLICALLWEAPONIZED MICINE.
UNLIEVLE.
DR. KARYHANKOU FOR SPEAKING OUT.
THANYOU
>> REPLICANS HAD A VERY,ERY
STRONG ECTION WITHHE R'SRECORD O
MOREHAN FOURILLION MORE
REPUBLICANS, OWINNING STATE
WIDE IN ALST ERY BATE
GRNDTATE PROVES AT THE
TURNOUWORK FM AN RNC
STDPOI WE IPPETHE HOUSE
D OUR GRND GE WORKED.
>> Laura: ASSAID LAST NIGHT
I SAID ATHE P OF THE SHOW, EVER
LIS 'RONA DANIEL A LOT SHE'S
WONDERFUL PERS B THE
RESUS SPK FOR THSELVES.
SHS RIGHT ABOUT E HOUSE
IPPI BUT IT'S TI FOR
CHAN AT THE C.HER TENIER NEEDS .
EVERY CUMBIN THE SENATE
RUINFOR SENA STAYED IN THE
SENATETHERE WANO RUBLICAN FLIPS
ANY OF THE SEA HELD BY
INNOCENT DEMRATS.
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT?WHAT ABO EARL?
SAYSHE PARTY TNSITIONS INTO
THIS N GENATION I PE OF
ELECTED LEERSHIP, THIS H TO BE .
RLIETODAY CONGREMAN LE
ZELD SAID HE WLD N BE RUNNING N
REELECON PRE BAKEDY DESIGN.
BUT HE ALSO SAID TDOESN'T
MEANHE SULD BE RUNNING
AGN.
NOW, ITHE C WANTTO COMPLETELY I
ROOTS  THE PARTY, WELL, TH CAN
O.BUT I THINK EY'RE GOING TOE R
OUT L OSE FUND RSING LETTERS ANN
RETURN.
IT'S TIME TO LOOK FONE
LEERSHIP THAT WI REVITALIZE
THE RNC AND HELP THE PTYOVE
TOICTO AFTER VICTORY IN
20.
ANTHATOULD MEAN SUPPTING
R NEXT GUEST.
INING MEOW HMEET DLON RNC
COITTEWOMAN FROM CIFORNIA
NDIDATE FOR RNC AIR FULLDISCLOS
YOU FOABOU25 YEARS WE BOTH
WENT TDARTOT AND THE SAME LAW S
YOUNGER THATE ME LKY GL.
T I'VE KNOWN YND I CAN SAY
TH FULCANDOR TBEEN AS
WAYSRY TO BEANDID.
YOU ARE A COUMMATE
PROFESSION AND YOUON'T TAKE
AP FROM ANYONEND Y DO IT
WITH A SMI.
BUT  IT PRE BAD THATONNA
DANIEL STAYS OAS RNC CHAIR?
>> THANK YOUOR HAVING ME LAURAA
FES TH WAY HE PROBAB RAN
IN A BRICK WALL BY TSE WHO
RE MADE A T OFROMISES  THE CHAI
CHAIR OF TNC THO FACRS
MAKET DAUNTINGI'MAKING CALLS TM
HEARING LOT OF DISGRUNLED
MEMBS WHO WANT CNGE BUT
TH'RE RAID.
BECAUSE THERS A CULTURE IF Y
DON'T PLAYALL WITH THE CHAAND T
INSIDE THEELTW Y'LL BE FUN
I SHOULD.
U MANOT GET PLUMOMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS, YR STATE MAY NO
GET TRANSFERTO T BUILDING FUND,.
THIS CTUREF RETRIBION AND
SORTF ANSACTIONAL
RELATIONSHS IS NOT WHAT
RNS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT.
IT'S SPOSETO BE OUT
ELECTING REPUBLICANSLL OVE
E COUNTRY D I'VE BN
APLLED WHAT I HED E LA
O WES AS I BEG TO MA
PHONE CALLS TOEMBERS.
PLEDGE TO RN THAT ARND
LAURWE CANT HAVE A TOPOWN
COULTANT DRIVEN 902,000 ERA GET
RECT MAIL D NODOFFICNT
CHANS THAT ARE NECSARY TO
MPETE WITH THE DOCRATS.
THAREN RUNNING CAMPANS
LIKE THEY RE BK IN T DAY
EY ARE ABSOLUTELY AGGRSIVELY
AND JUST BTALLY ON EVERY
NOVAON IN LAW ON EVERY
INNOVATION STAING 1-C 3s AND
FAKE N-PROTS THAT DOHE
WORK OTHE DEMOCRS AND  ARE
NOT INNOTING.WE ARE NOT LEANG.
OUR MESSAGG IS NOT CLEARND DEVI.
>> Laura: IT STEAL T
>>E ARE NOT TIVATING THE BASE.
Laura: BY THEAY, MSNBC
DON'HAVEO PLHE SOUND
BITEUT SUFFICE IT  SAY THE
FA THAT 'RSO WORRIED ABOUT
YO THAT TELLME ERYTHING I
NE TO KN, NAMELYHAT U'RE
E RIGHT PERSON FOR THE JOB
THEY'RE LIKE, WELL, SHE COULBE
PROBMATIC.
HAEET WE'RGOINFOR VERING
THIS I WT TO BE FA TO